[Music]
is this true that you worked as a
surrogate on President Obama's I can't
pass I on behalf of the president a
number of times in both elections in
2008 and this one but it all culminated
on election night this year I was in
Chicago I was 40 feet away from the
podium where he accepted his victory
just stood in the same spot for five
hours like claimed that space and you
know was just with a bunch of other
citizens of the country and it was
unbelievable you know when you first
worked on the campaign I guess the first
time around I've heard you describe how
you were just one of many people but
this time you actually got a little face
time with the president oh we did they
brought a group of us when the president
was in LA in the summertime to kind of
kick off the campaign and get us all
motivated and involved and by us I mean
the other surrogates a lot of people
from you know the entertainment industry
that that go out and travel for him and
speak on his behalf and he was super
cool but the first time I met him he
gave me the not the finger but the spa
well he gave you the volca new route of
people he was sort of being ushered down
the way and he caught me in the back and
he was like what's that I was like I
really want to hang out with you so much
more now you're cool are you sure he
just wasn't like a slightly broken wave
maybe you're reading into it
I did do a frame-by-frame play with it
confirmation by and you yeah what's true